good evening and welcome my name is
Philip Khoury I'm the Dean of the School
of Humanities Arts and Social Sciences
here at MIT and I'm a professor of
history it's a privilege to introduce
this event which is titled America at
war a conversation with Helen Thomas our
sponsors the communications forum at MIT
and I've been asked just to make one
brief announcement before we proceed and
that is this Wednesday at 5:00 p.m. in
this room in Bartos theater
there will be the third communications
forum form the third fora if you like
okay on copyright and the two featured
speakers are Jonathan Zittrain at
Harvard and Siva Vaidhyanathan at NYU
and we urge you to come out for this I
gather it's been a very successful
couple of forums so far now for more
than four decades with pen and paper in
hand Helen Thomas has occupied a front
row seat in a theater where the
principal cast and the plot change every
four years or occasionally every eight
as a young writer she began covering a
newly elected president in November 1960
and then marked the transition from his
administration to the subsequent one
after his assassination
she has monitored presidential political
and military policies relating to
conflicts from Vietnam to the former
Soviet Union to Israel to the Falklands
to Libya and to Iraq she has written
about political scandals that have
involved wiretapping arms sales to Rouge
militants and love affairs with interns
she sits now
yeah I knew that would go down well Alex
okay she sits now pen still at the ready
offering commentary on measures mean
taking to stimulate our languishing
economy on policies that bear on our
role in Iraq and on the dozens of issues
that will emerge as the dominos tumble
after tomorrow's midterm elections
indeed as a member of the White House
press corps since 1960 Helen Thomas has
been reporting important national and
international stories in which nine US
presidents have played the lead she is a
legend in her own time which means she
is someone who refuses to live off her
many laurels by remaining as active and
as engaged as ever with her profession
of journalism on behalf of all of us
Helen I'm honoured to welcome you to MIT
I know this is your first visit and I
will confess that I knew her as a little
boy she wasn't much older than me then
so it's a wonderful reunion for me as a
longtime
eyewitness to history Helens
perspectives on politics and the state
of the Free Press are even more relevant
and valuable today and they will be
tomorrow
certainly as reporters and as
participants in public debates about
democracy about civil liberties about
foreign policy Helen Thomas and her
colleagues in the media serve an
important role in helping us to
understand what's happening on the
political stage to explore alternative
points of view and to decide what we as
participants in a democratic society
should do ought to do such an important
role doesn't come without scrutiny
however as we have come to question the
press as much if not more than the
players it covers what responsibility
and accountability do the media have to
the citizens they serve what is the
media's responsibility to the
individuals organizations and
institutions
it covers Helen will address these
questions in relation to our current
situation in Iraq spotlighting the role
of the free press to both question and
to endorse and she'll explain how the
two have become either too entwined at
times
spin becomes news or entirely polarized
that papers too liberal or that ones too
conservative following Helens remarks we
will turn to our two respondents Charles
Stewart on my far right always on my far
right and David Thorburn David very
kindly has agreed to step forward on
very short notice to replace Henry
Jenkins who has been called away quite
suddenly and regrets that he cannot be
here has a personal issue that he had to
deal with out of town Charles Stewart is
professor of political science at MIT
and associate dean of our school he also
happens to be one of this country's
leading scholars of American politics
and behavior he'll offer a response
emerging from his extensive research on
the US Congress
David is professor of literature at MIT
and he's of course the director of the
communications forum and has been for a
good long while now our sponsor today
David is a media studies expert and is
one of the pioneers of television
studies in the United States and I want
to add that both David Thorburn and
Charles Stewart hold the highest honor
we have in the teaching world at MIT
both our faculty McVicar faculty fellows
there is no higher honor in my opinion
at this institution we're ready to begin
we're going to begin with our featured
speaker Helen Thomas welcome Helen
well it's always hard to hear your
obituary but I have never had it done
more intellectually and as for the
questions I'm gonna leave that to the
experts good afternoon
or is it evening I'm very honored to be
here but I must admit when I told my
friends that I was going to MIT they
said why you can't add two and two and
there you'll be with all those nobels
and future Einsteins but I did come on
the eve eve of the midterm elections and
I don't have any of those answers either
my crystal ball is murky short of
predictions but long on hopes that the
Democrats will keep control of the
Senate it is up for grabs
they have only one seat in the majority
now otherwise you can be sure it will be
bombs away I can say that now because I
write an opinion column when I worked
for UPI wire service I had to stick to
the facts and now I'm allowed to have an
opinion forgive everyone free at last
and now I wake up in the morning and I
say to myself who do I hate today
and then that's the that's the way you
write a column when I first wrote my
first column the editor said where's the
edge said the what your opinion my what
after 50 years of censoring myself
anyway it's fun well I never beat around
the bush excuse the pun I hate war
besides I've lived long enough to see so
many of our reviled enemies become our
friends so maybe there is a better way
instead of The Killing Fields I've never
covered a president before in all my
years in Washington who actually wanted
to go to war first resort not not the
end of diplomacy not the
end of talk not the end of negotiations
others would go of course but in this
case it's the first resort Iraq has been
on President Bush's radar since he came
into office and even before whenever it
seems that he may be easing up his
cordon of hawk and harlot hardline
advisors rein him in not that he is not
obsessed Saddam Hussein is his white
whale it's more than that he and his
cohorts are pursuing a policy that is
alien to all that we've ever stood for
since World War two at least in terms of
collective security containment peaceful
diplomacy peaceful negotiations the bush
policy of pre-emptive war is immoral
historian Arthur Schlesinger historian
Arthur Schlesinger thank you put it well
he said that such a policy would
legitimatize Pearl Harbor but he has
given a green light President Bush has
given a had been given a green light
from Congress so it's once more into the
breach with none of the lessons learned
since Vietnam sure we'll win that war
bombed the Iraqis who are left bomb them
into a democracy no other country is
really with us on this Tony Blair is
apparently not speaking for the British
people on this one the Air Force has
been doing practice runs in southern
Iraq and do I dare to assume that it was
hoped that some Iraqi will be pool a
foolhardy enough to give Bush an excuse
for the war that he longs for where are
the peacemakers I thought we had to
retaliate in Afghanistan but perpetual
war war without end is hardly what
anyone would want to look forward to for
their children for their children
the grandchildren what a way to begin
the 21st century and we thought that we
were going to live happily ever after
when the Cold War ended I have to admit
the Bush i'ts have played the war card
well the economy prescription drugs
other domestic issues have been pushed
aside rightfully so because clearly they
have no answers but well beyond this
country if Bush actually gets a
Republican Senate and House start
drilling oil in Alaska
forget Enron and the corporate greed
give those hungry Wall Street investors
a cut in the Social Security benefits
well I say Cry the Beloved Country we
have arrived at a stage where there are
no ideals no inspiration no hope it's
not only a swing to the right it's a big
slide away from the values and
principles that have made this country
so great we have seen Americans too
willing to give up their freedom for
security bigbrother style darkness at
noon as well as Orwell it's odd for me
to quote Bob Baer the conservative
congressman barb I'm sorry who said that
the real test of freedom is not during
periods of peace and prosperity but in
times of national crisis I must say I
was surprised that some great Ivy League
academic defenders of civil liberties
were so willing to jump over to the
other side when they felt that the
country was threatened and to be as
vengeful as anyone else who has never
asked why the Attorney General had ruled
that deportation cases should be closed
to the public and the press fed up the
Detroit Papers finally sued and won a
ruling for to be able to cover some of
these deportation
hearings and federal judge Damon Keith
said democracy dies behind closed doors
we are so willing to accept an
unprovoked war as the United States
builds up its forces in the Persian Gulf
where is the outrage preemptive war is
not us
I maintain at least it wasn't us in the
twentieth century but we are being led
to permanent perpetual war by a man who
did not choose to serve himself when he
was about to be drafted for Vietnam and
that goes for all of his Hawk advisors I
don't think that's a low blow it's the
truth it's not it's not lost on the
American people that President Bush is
giving a pass to diplomatic talks that
is to North Korea which admits it lied
and has nuclear weapons in production or
and wants to produce them as a program
and we are going to bomb Iraq which may
have them someday does that make sense
to you
of course or is it the oil that Iraq
possesses anyone want to send their sons
or grandchildren to die for a grab and
rocks oil fields would we tolerate an
attack on our nation that way when are
the American people going to wake up in
the case of Afghanistan I felt that the
the retribution was swift and right the
question to question to question to
dissent is not unpatriotic it is
patriotic to be a thinking people and
not to roll over as Congress did for
fear that they will not get reelected
without thinking of the consequences we
should be working for true arms control
all over the world
we should uphold the treaties that we
have made since World War two that are
being torn up day by day Comprehensive
Test Ban Treaty non-proliferation
in treaty any ballistic missile treaty
and so forth all the others that we
signed since World War two we have even
forgotten that we need friends and
allies we forgot that at least till nine
twelve then the president was never off
the phone for three weeks calling
everyone in the world all the leaders in
the world lining him up Colin Powell
Secretary of State was a lonesome dog
but he likes his job and there's no room
in this administration for a devil's
advocate President Bush has had only six
news conferences in his two years in
office that's a long time between drinks
and that is playing it safe but not
consistent with true democracy the
presidential and he has his last news
conference was on July 8th a lot has
happened since then the presidential
news conference is the only forum in our
society where a president can be
questioned on a regular basis and held
accountable otherwise he can rule and is
ruling now by executive order
autocratically imperialistic Lee I
maintain that is not us and that's not
democracy you cannot have a democracy
without a free press free to ask
questions it's indispensable in our
system well what a difference a day
makes what a difference a year makes
we've had to tighten security like never
before now that we know that we are
vulnerable not protected by two oceans I
know I sound like the bearer of bad news
blame the messenger for used to that no
question our world has been shaken
shattered maybe but I am confident that
we shall overcome as Franklin D
Roosevelt put it at the height of the
Great Depression we have nothing to fear
but fear itself the philosopher George
Santayana said that if we do not learn
from our mistakes we are doomed to
repeat them in the future
it is ours to reason why not just to do
and die we have to wake up speak up play
a role in the decisions that affect all
mankind it's up to us to make our public
servants accountable we in the press are
the self-appointed self anointed
watchdogs of democracy we try to follow
the truth wherever it leads us as long
as I'm on my rant I think we also have
to protect our civil liberties Benjamin
Franklin said if we are willing to give
up our Liberty for temporary security we
are in danger of losing both I speak of
wiretapping indiscriminate random FBI
accessing email lists FBI listening in
on private lawyer client conversations
rounding up dark-skinned immigrants who
have no appeal no due process some 700
detainees at Guantanamo but they held in
limbo unable to contact any member of
their family or a lawyer of course they
are prisoners of war denied rights under
international law and the Geneva Accords
that's not us the international world is
wondering what happened to America's
great heart and soul sabotage the
biological chemical weapons treaty we we
have opposed the the Criminal Court and
so forth we're going to put nuclear
weapons in our last sanctuary the
heavens Winston Churchill said the
democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
that have been invented and I like what
Adlai Stevenson said Stevenson said
democracy is great not just because the
majority prevails but because it's safe
to be in the minority
it's also said that the only way for
evil to prevail is for good people to do
nothing I shall never forget the Martin
Luther King march on Washington in 1963
when he made his immortal speech I have
a dream black and white kids walking
hand-in-hand together but I also
remember the rabbi who had been spent
many years in a concentration camp in
the Hitler regime and he said that the
greatest sin of all in the Nazi era was
silence the French historian historian
de Tocqueville spoke of America in its
infancy and visited here he said America
is great because it is good when it
ceases to be good it will no longer be
great to me great presidents have great
goals for mankind I believe that they
have the greatest honor that can come to
anyone and that is the trust of the
American people
I've always felt greatly privileged to
cover the White House and to have that
ringside seat to instant history history
in the making
I've seen presidents highs and lows
always aware that they are human beings
sometimes I thought I'd give you a
thumbnail sketch of the presidents I've
covered John F Kennedy most inspired of
them all anyone who would say we're
going to land men on the moon in a
decade was either reading science
fiction or obviously had that vision
thing he said there's a universe out
there that we must explore he was a
statesman at the time of the Cuban
Missile Crisis he avoided a nuclear
holocaust lyndon b johnson 'he's great
society helped the poor the sick and the
maimed he rammed through congress in his
first two years in office on the
Tailwind of the kennedy assassination
Medicare the Civil Rights Act
voting rights for blacks for the first
time in the south when they didn't have
to recite the US Constitution or pay a
poll-tax to register to vote
public housing federal aid to education
at all levels from headstart through
college you name it
but of course Vietnam was his Dana MA
like most presidents Johnson had a
stable of speech writers and once he
once asked for that a certain speech to
be prepared and when the speech trod
writer brought him the first draft he
looked at it and he said bull tear bowl
chair people I'm going to talk to don't
know who Bowl chair is grabbed a pen
scratches out bull chair and scribbled
in as my dear old daddy used to say and
when when he was pushing civil rights a
group of a southern cronies he had been
Senate Majority Leader came to him and
said Lyndon what is this when you were
in the Senate you were a southerner and
he said I'm president now president of
all the people he knew every man's price
on Capitol Hill and he knew where all
the bodies were buried Richard Nixon
brilliant politician who always had two
roads to go and he always took the wrong
road he will be remembered for the
breakthrough trip to China in 1972
starting which began the normalization
of relations between the US and China
after a 20-year hiatus 20-year gap and
he will be remembered as the only
president in our history to be forced to
resign because of the abuse of
government power his dark side always
prevailed Gerald Ford restored
confidence in the White House and in the
country in the aftermath of the
Watergate scandal
he said the long nightmare is over Jimmy
Carter put human rights at the
centerpiece of his foreign policy he
also is the most respected past
president of recent times and hats off
that he won the Nobel Peace Prize
finally after being nominated ten times
Ronald Reagan moved the country to the
right there was a Reagan Revolution he
also abetted the end of the Cold War
with a tremendous arms build-up George
Bush 41 best known for the Persian Gulf
War victory but we couldn't read his
lips when it came to the economy
Bill Clinton tarnished the Oval Office
with his personal liaisons but he did
bring prosperity to the country balance
the budget he worked for World Peace in
the Balkans Ireland Middle East and when
he was getting ready to leave office of
course all the White House reporters
wanted to interview him and we all had
the pro forma questions will you write
your memoirs what will your legacy be
but I think I asked him one prophetic
question I said to a mr. president if
you could take one thing from the White
House that belongs to the American
people what would it be well I didn't
know he was gonna bring a u-haul he said
it would be the moon rock which was
brought back by Neil Armstrong first man
to land on the moon and he said that
whenever his staff were in high tension
at each other's throats he would tell
them to chill out and point to the moon
rock and note that it's 3.6 billion
years old and that's what we call
perspective George W Bush 43 a work in
progress he has raised more than 125
million for the Republican candidates
his cordon of the of advisors as I've
told you were all hardliners he likes
being president no sweat
he asked for advice on one-page
presidency has always been on the job
training so we'll forgive him his
philosophy is simple black and white
good and evil dead or alive with us or
against us except when it comes to the
transgressions of the greedy corporate
world
and then he says you really can't reduce
this problem to black and white I went
to Washington during World War two
determined to be a newspaper woman I
just gotten out of college and Liz
carpenter who also became a great she
became a great Texas newspaper woman and
later press secretary to Lady Bird
Johnson arrived at the same time she had
just graduated from the University of
Texas and we both went knocking on doors
at the national press building and Liz
was always on the plump side and she ran
out of money a couple days before I did
and she wired her brother please send me
$200 or I'm going to have to sell my
body and he wired back sell it by the
pound all the first ladies I covered all
the first ladies I covered rose to the
occasion they found out that they had
great power and they could wave a magic
wand in support of a good social cause
and many supported their Crusades long
after they left the White House and mrs.
Johnson's of course was known for her
national beautification program which
transformed this land we loved and she
has created a wildflower center outside
of Austin and a teacher took a group of
her schoolchildren one day to the visit
the center and she held up a photograph
of Lady Bird Johnson and asked the kids
do you know who she is and one little
boy piped up that's mother nature of
course the White House is always under
scrutiny and somehow presidents seem to
think they can have their privacy my
feeling is that they want their privacy
and that's the issue don't go into
public life I also think that if you
really want to go into public life you
should decide at the age of five and
live accordingly when I was first
assigned to cover president - elect
Jimmy Carter I thought of that interview
he had given to Playboy magazine where
he said he had lust in his heart well
little did I know that presidential
bus would come much later instead I
found myself covering a sunday-school
teacher and when I tried to cover
Carter's Bible class in Plains Georgia
my male colleagues were allowed in but I
was blocked by a big burly bouncer I
finally convinced him I was no lady I
was a reporter forgive us our press
passes well nope no president has ever
liked the press dating back to George
Washington I wasn't covering him but
Kennedy said I'm reading more and
enjoying it less what LBJ said is
unprintable Nixon looked up when we
walked into the Cabinet Room one day and
said it's only coincidental that we're
talking about pollution when the press
walks in President Ford said that of God
had created the world in six days he
could not have rested he would have had
to explain it to Helen Thomas Carter
always seemed to be saying Lord forgive
them for they know not what they do and
when President Reagan was told that the
Sandinistas the Marxist had fired on a
press helicopter at the Honduran border
he quipped there's some good in everyone
and when a friend asked President
Clinton why the press always went along
in the motorcade when he went jogging he
laughed and said they just want to see
if I drop dead that's true
George Bush used to invite my George
Bush one just invite my younger
colleagues to go jogging with him better
than than me I got invited to the
dedication of the horseshoe pit well al
al Neuharth the founder of USA Today
said that when he went to Cuba
to interview Fidel Castro a couple of
years ago he found that Castro was very
clued in about America happenings here
and he asked Castro what's the
difference between your country and mine
and Castro said I don't have to answer
questions from Helen Thomas well as we
start the 21st century I think that we
can look back on the last century in
deepest gratitude to the millions who
made the ultimate sacrifice for us two
world wars Korea Vietnam at the same
time we also realized that we've made
great strides in the last century which
have brought us great credit in terms of
civil rights women's rights human rights
not to mention the high-tech advances
robotics and so forth we're going to
Mars and so forth and we know that our
quest for knowledge should never end I
have many memories than covering the
White House
they've been times to laugh times to cry
and times to wonder I remember when
Kennedy said an off-the-cuff remark at a
news conference life is unfair and I
remember when we asked him what would
happen if on Air Force one we asked him
what would happen if the aircraft
crashed I know one thing he said your
name will be just a footnote and I
remember when we were invited to the LBJ
Ranch for dinner and Johnson asked Bill
Moyers who had been a Baptist minister
to say grace Moyer's bent his head began
to pray Johnson commanded Speak Up bill
I wasn't talking to you mister president
Moyers replied and I remember when
Johnson was taken to Bethesda Naval
Hospital for gallbladder surgery the
psychiatric ward had been transformed
into a press
what happened to the patient's Johnson a
s'mores we gave them all press cards
said lawyers and then there was Mitch
Costanza who said I don't mind Carter
being born again but did he have to come
back as himself and I remember asking
Billy Carter if he too had been born
again he said once is enough nanda was
my all-time favorite miss Lillian
Carter's mother who said sometimes when
I look at my children I wish I had
remained a virgin when Carter was
elected president
a reporter ran up to miss Lillian and
said aren't you proud of your son she
said which one I remember interviewing
her during the Carter campaign she was
still fuming over a Frenchwoman
correspondent who had been labored
Carter's campaign promise never to lie
she kept asking mr. Lynn what he really
mean by that finally she said to mr.
lully and do you lie miss Lillian said
well I might tell a little white lie
well what do you mean by a little white
lie in total exasperation miss Lillian
said you remember when you came through
that door and I told you how beautiful
you looked well that's a little white
lie several years ago on Christmas in
the Christmas season the Washington Post
said the General Colin Powell was going
to become President Clinton's Secretary
of State well a little premature he
that's what he is now and I was invited
to a Christmas party at Sam Donaldson's
house Powell was there in my usual shy
way I marched up to him and I said
general are you going to be the next
Secretary of State to which he turned to
another guest and said isn't there some
war we can send her to well before 9/11
he sent me a note saying I'm still
looking for that war and I sent him back
the Vietnam slogan hell no I won't go
and then there was Henry Kissinger woman
ran up to Kissinger and said Oh dr.
Kissinger thank you for saving the world
he said you're welcome
and once once once once Kissinger teach
his own Secret Service agents that he
might be kidnapped base by terrorists
they told him don't worry we'll never
let them take you alive and I remember
going to Moscow with President Reagan
for a summit meeting with Mikhail
Gorbachev suddenly the evil empire was
no more in Reagan's eyes and he noted
that the Russians laughed and they cried
and they were human when we got back to
Washington I said to him mr. president
do you think if you had gone to Moscow
ten years ago 20 years ago you might
have found out the Russians laughed they
cried they're human they're not bearers
who walked like men he said nope they've
changed Justice Brandeis said that if
the government becomes a lawbreaker it
breeds contempt for the law he also said
that a constant spotlight on public
officials lessens the possibility of
corruption Lincoln said let the people
know the facts and the country will be
safe I believe that Jefferson said
eternal vigilance is the price of
Liberty engraved in the mantle in the
State Dining Room it's a prayer by John
Adams which says blessings on this house
may only good and wise men live here we
all hope for that and I believe that
people can handle the truth and they
deserve no less and we should keep an
eye on presidents who have
life-and-death power over all humanity
today to keep our people informed
democracy alive thank you
thank you thank you very much Helen we
will now move on to David Thorburn has
you know we work together this is how it
is David is elected to speak first
in response thank you I will I won't
even attempt to be as as witty or as
charming as Helen Thomas but I would
like to begin by giving you an
examination a test it's a pop quiz among
her many allusions and references Helen
Thomas made reference to a poem by
Tennyson in her talk did anyone pick up
on it what was it yes she said she spoke
briefly she said ours is not to reason
why and of course she was referring to a
very famous poem which is deeply
relevant to our discourse in some
respects and I thought I might begin by
mentioning it to you it's of course the
the the famous poem that Tennyson wrote
after the catastrophe of a brigade of
light cavalry being ordered by the
during the Crimean War being ordered to
charge in two incredibly overwhelming
canons checked it was it was a horrific
military blunder a mistake on a
monumental scale to send light cavalry
in into the face of those guns and there
was an elaborate investigation
afterwards and and and and and the great
national act of mourning commemoration
and and self-flagellation in england
after the event and it was partly caused
by the power of Tennyson's famous poem
and in the poem he describes some of the
power of the moment has to do with it's
astonishing rhythms but one of the lines
in the poem goes something like this
cannon to the right of them cannon to
the left of them volleyed and thundered
stormed at with shot and shell boldly
they rode and well into the valley of
death rode the six hundred
600 cavalry men rode into those cannon
even as they began it they knew that it
was a that they were riding to their
deaths I think the more sensible leader
might have actually disobeyed orders and
sent his men back to away from the front
but they were they were they were too
honorable and too full of sort of that
we have to obey our obey our orders and
some of the lines in the poem talk
someone had blundered is one of the
lines in the poem and one of the reasons
that it strikes me as relevant to our
present situation it is in some sense
disturbing and eerie to me because one
difference between our contemporary
situation and the situation in the 19th
century I could imagine
easily and I think Helen Thomas's
discourse implies a and an equally
horrific and maybe even more shocking
blunder if it's a preemptive strike by
American forces on tort on on others but
the but the difficult of course as all
of you are thinking I'm sure is that our
forces would be high in the air free of
danger the civilian the the civilian
casualties are likely to be horrific the
cost even if it's a horrific blunder the
cost will be to the enemy and the
country responsible for the higher will
not is likely not to feel it part of the
danger of bush it strikes me part of the
danger of what president bush's has been
talking about although perhaps less
aggressively in recent days then then at
the beginning of his of his discourse
about pre-emptive war part of the danger
of it is precisely that if we go down
that road we are much less likely
immediately to feel the consequences of
such behavior horrible as it is the of
the 600 members of the Light Brigade who
charged into the mouth of fell something
over 400 of them were killed and a
shocking a shark in casualty rate but it
was a wake-up call to that to that
society and to those people in a way
such wake-up calls may be less available
in a high-tech environment in which war
is conducted by digital technology and
high-flying airplanes and so-called
smart bombs
so it strikes me as a irrelevant and
disturbing imperfect analogy I wanted to
I also thought it would it was worth
saying what I take it most of you were
felt I think that Helen Thomas offered
us a very powerful indictment of the
current behavior of the Bush presidency
from which I certainly have no
significant dissent I think that the
notion of pre-emptive war is as dubious
and as vulnerable as Helen Thomas
suggested I think her comments about the
implicit incoherence and inconsistency
of the Bush policies are especially
notable and worth recalling and also her
reminder to us of the extraordinary
danger to civil liberties in the country
that has already begun to build because
of the rhetoric of the administration
deserves I think underlining but her
most powerful but for me the most
powerful and disturbing aspect of our
discourse maybe it's that I don't expect
that much from the from the from the
collection of of managers and and oil
company apologists who surround
President Bush the most shocking thing
to me in some ways that that Helen
Thomas dwelled on a bit mentioned a bit
and then I think we might want to talk
more about in our conversation has been
the astonishing su penis of the Congress
the astonishing the absolutely
astonishing truly shocking cowardly
behavior of most Democrats it's it's
quite amazing that Helen Thomas said you
know in her in her talk today was 50
times more eloquent than almost any
democratic politician has been in public
about the shocking inconsistency and
folly of this administration's behavior
our our democratic car is the Democratic
Congress so nervous about it's
ridiculous jobs that it is afraid to
speak the truth in a moment like this
that strikes me as almost more shocking
and more horrible because they know
better because they know at least Bush
presumably believes what he's doing
maybe perhaps believes what he's doing
in any case some of the some of the war
mongers in his in his administration
Richard
Perle and and and the Secretary of
Defense surely believe what they're
doing contemptible as those beliefs may
be there are many Democratic politicians
who know perfectly well how shocking and
inconsistent and and morally dubious as
well as politically impractical these
plans are but they're silent about it
and it strikes me as in that sense a
very very depressing time for our for
our for supposedly for our democracy let
me end with a with a with a little
reminiscence of my own about the Vietnam
era and in that in this sense I have at
least one minorly optimistic thing to
say to you in response to the kinds of
thoughts that Helen Thomas's discourse
generated in me I was very active as a
relatively active in my in my graduate
student days and in my days in my early
days as a young professor in the
anti-war movement against the war in
Vietnam and and one of the most
important things that I recall about
that time is seems to me to lead to at
least a partly optimistic conclusion
after all the negative things that I've
been saying and that Helen Thomas has
said and that is that in the very early
days of the anti-war movement in in the
United States during the Vietnam era in
the in the early 1960s in 1961 62 63 the
year of Kennedy's assassination when we
began to send advisors to Vietnam
without that was never in the beginning
even any formal declaration of our
involvement there the the amount of
anti-war discourse in the larger
population was relatively small there
was very you would never read an op-ed
piece in The New York Times questioning
the the motives of the war and it was as
late as 1965 or 1966 that the secretary
of state of the United States Dean Rusk
said there is no significant body of
opinion in this country this is almost a
direct quotation I used it many times in
my anti-war talks in the 1960s no
significant body of opinion this bastard
said no significant body of opinion in
United States as opposed to the war in
Vietnam by the time he said that in 1965
many you
versity campuses were hotbeds of
anti-war activity but the truth is that
none of the anti-war activity at the in
those in those early in those in in
those early stages came from public
sources either so we didn't we weren't
hearing from congressmen we weren't
hearing from senators in those in those
early days but it is still the case I
think that that that the present
situation in the in our present
situation one of the the prime
difference that I see between those days
and now is that even though the
politicians are keeping their mouths
shut and are behaving with I think
contemptible cowardice and self-interest
probably mistaken self-interest ordinary
people are speaking out there is more on
the op-ed pages there's more on the talk
shows and the on radio there's more
general fear and opposition to any
proposal to invade Iraq bubbling in our
society now then was remotely the case
as late as 1965 or even 1966 in the and
that's I think a positive my guess is my
belief is that if the Bush
administration really is so foolish as
to pursue some sort of a pre-emptive war
the amount of anti-war the explosion of
anti-war activity into the streets will
be surprising to everyone except those
of us who remember the Vietnam era and
and and and remember what what can
happen when when when an aroused
citizenry begins to instruct its
government about what constitutes
reasonable behavior at least that's what
I hope will happen if Bush is so foolish
as to go down that road
so this is um too difficult uh max to
follow
not only have we heard two very
compelling views about about the state
of the world today but I teach a
freshman advising seminar those of you
most people here are probably men mighty
and know about these things and I'm
teaching about cooking doing a cooking
class actually this term and about an
hour and a half ago we were making and
eating wontons and I have a belly full
of them right about there and so I'm
gonna be looking down on my notes a
little more than I would like just to
kind of get over the wanton problem we
shall call it but all my notes I kind of
a feeling that the conversation would go
this way I want to say something that I
think is ultimately in the spirit of
what both Helen Thomas and David have
said but come at it in a slightly
different way and actually suggests that
in the politics of going to war with
Iraq perhaps going to war with Iraq over
the last couple of months there's them
both the supine behavior but there's
also been an interesting debate and an
interesting dynamic and public opinion
and I'm curious about the degree to
which this this pattern might emerge
going forward and so let me kind of lay
out my argument a bit and to kind of see
where it goes and I'm going to start off
perhaps a bit maybe even overly
conventional into political science II
but then come back to what I hope is the
hopeful point here and so in any case
even going to war is a pretty awful
thing and miss Thomas mentioned in the
beginning that there were lessons of
Vietnam and and there's one lesson of
Vietnam that I think we all understand
hawks and doves and that is that a
nation shouldn't be dragged into war
without the public's approval another
lesson that was learned within
Washington at least and is less well
understood is that well the president
shouldn't go to war without Congress's
approval and that's certainly what we
witnessed and September was watching a
president try to get Congress's approval
of course these two things go together
the public that the president wants to
get the approval from is not a VAE it's
an it
and this public can't ask questions it
can't speak with one voice that's what's
Congress is therefore and so these two
things go together getting Congress's
approval in getting the public's
approval go together and during the
months of September and October we saw
this dance between the president and the
Congress over what precisely should Iraq
policy be and the interesting thing of
course is that you know this is a
society where secrets aren't easily kept
and that dance took place in public and
as a consequence of what was relatively
a narrow debate within Washington there
was nonetheless the development of quite
sophisticated public opinion that um I
would say and probably a little less
passionately but nonetheless agree with
what David just said and that is you
know the spirit of that and that is
moving forward there's been a ground
laid a groundwork lay that hasn't been
there in many other adventures around
the world and so here's sort of the I
guess the the hopeful scenario Americans
don't like to talk about foreign policy
we know that they hate it on what they
like to think about is there is there a
world they'd like to think about the
price of potato chips and they'd like to
think about whether their kids have good
schools and the rest and this shows up
in public opinion all the time and in
fact on Pew Center for the research and
the people in the press asked in October
likely voters a bunch of questions and
they actually asked them to two
questions that got a lot of attention
one was what is the the thing that
you've been talking about most in terms
of national politics and the thing
they've been talking about the most was
Iraq in fact along the long list that we
all know of issues that one could talk
about and September in October they were
talking about Iraq more than half more
than terrorism more than the economy nor
more than Enron more than anything else
then there are asked well what would you
like to talk about it wasn't Iraq not
surprisingly it was the economy it was
terrorism
it was education and it was the rest now
a number of my friends my Liberal
Democratic friends have taken this news
as being really horrible and is
evidence actually the politics isn't
working in America and the evidence is
this that Americans really want to be
talking about the sorry state of the
economy and it's a pretty sorry state of
the economy and any other midterm
election we would expect the Republicans
to be getting hammered right now because
the poor state of the economy and we
would not be wondering right now whether
Republicans are going to whether the
Democrats could possibly pick up seats
in the Senate or the or the house we
would just be assuming it but things are
really really different right now okay
so Americans want to talk about the
economy with them even they've been led
to talk about Iraq well I think it's a
great thing they've been led to talk
about Iraq quite frankly and I think
it's a great thing that we have a press
that has figured out in Washington what
the important issue is so while it is a
sad thing I might do my liberal
democratic hat to think that we're
coming into a midterm in which the poor
economic performance cannot be an issue
and in which we cannot blast the
incumbent president for that nonetheless
the press was focused on rather the
people were focused on Iraq in September
and October and the reason they were
focused on Iraq was there was a drama
going on in Washington as bad a drama as
that was and that drama was over whether
delay and army and all that actually not
delay but army and all those guys would
come along and support the president in
the end they did and in the process the
public developed a really kind of
interesting public opinion and it
certainly isn't a fully formed public
opinion is going to emerge even further
so at the beginning of September most
Americans believed we should go to war
against Iraq we should do it now and we
should do it without any of the world
coming along with us by the time the
resolution was passed the beginning of
October roughly the same number of
people said we should go to war with
Iraq but most Americans said we should
go only when our allies are with us only
when the UN is with us and only as a
last resort
they did not believe that a month ago so
somehow this is a very interesting
message got into that craniums of most
Americans who mostly want to think about
the prices and the grocery stores no
kids education they actually developed a
pretty sophisticated view on the
situation in Iraq so the responsibility
of the press is multifaceted in a time
of war and I think
a lot of times we focus on issues of
secrecy of the denial civil liberties
and the rest but an important thing that
I think that we've meant that we've
witnessed over the last couple of months
is the press continuing to point out the
important thing and the important thing
right now is that as Helen Thomas was
pointing out me America used to not be a
nation of pre-emptive war now we might
be coming at a nation of pre-emptive war
and so I'll just conclude by saying the
hopeful thing and then asking the
question the hopeful thing again if you
haven't gotten the point is that a
dynamic has be gone in the public
discourse that like it or not the public
is gonna be talking about the Middle
East and about issues of war and are
gonna be dragged into developing a
sophisticated understanding of the issue
should we in fact owe the war and I
think it's actually less likely then
some people think that we will go to war
but should we go to war we're prepared
to talk about it in ways that we weren't
in other in other cases and that's an
interesting thing so the question really
becomes is there's a number of ways for
me to go from here one is to assume as
with David that once the once once the
war should a war happen that naturally
there be a revolt on college campuses
and naturally it will be will be
situated to resist mightily in my view
just having watched the last couple of
weeks for that to happen it would
require not only people in the street to
keep going but it also required the
press to keep the skeptical eye on a war
and on the one thing that hasn't been
hasn't really been touched on so far and
I would love to hear what you have to
say and what other people have to say is
that should we go to war with Iraq has
the would the sophisticated view or more
sophisticated view of the policy that
we're seeing in the press and we're
seeing the public develop would that
more sophisticated view continue to be
pushed in the press among members of the
press corps or is there a tendency even
at that point for not only the public
but and not only the Congress but then
the press with a real shooting war to
throttle back a bit and so I'll just you
know conclude by saying
you know agreeing that you know the the
guarantor of liberties in this country
is the press and Helen Thomas is worse a
day in her career our evidence that
without the press we would end up going
Pell willy nilly into some pretty
frightening policies and I think that
the best thing that we can hope for over
the next couple of years is continued
descent a continued sophisticated
analysis as much as we can get and as
public as we can get so just before we
open up to the floor
I thought Helen I don't know MIT has
certain traditions but not lots of them
but on this occasion if you wish you may
wish to respond to David or to Charles
or we can just go straight to the floor
it's up to you well I would like to say
that I was I'm thrilled to hear both of
you because you've given me a lot of
thoughts and it's nice to have a strong
support supporter and you gave me hope
because if the president goes to war
tomorrow the ball game is over but if
it's allowed to ferment as you said and
I really believe that people will really
begin to think what's this all about
Elfi and I honestly think that the more
we think about it the more we'll realize
how foolhardy it is except I think that
this president looking for any excuse
and will use any I mean if we're poor
during practice Robinson no-fly-zone
we're hoping they'll shoot us right I'm
a nerd have a good pretext to go to war
he's got none so far it hasn't been able
to sell it and they are they were very
open about it Karl Rove last January
issued a memo to all the Republican
operatives around the country maybe
that's the wrong word leaders to that
don't forget we've got the war card and
we're gonna play it and they have played
it and that's why it's on the agenda and
that's why it's in the conversation
the president has not made any speech
about the price of popcorn or anything
else he's definitely stayed on message
which is war and he's really psyched up
the people and think that he doesn't he
has not been accountable as I said
before as I complained before every day
I asked I read flusher when is a person
ever going to have another news
conference when you don't have one since
last July and you're taking a country
into war and there's no other way to
make them accountable we don't have a
prime minister going before a House of
Commons or being questioned so I'm
hoping that people will begin to think
but I also think in terms of the campus
you know the campuses were on fire
George Bush was that Yale he didn't even
know there was a war going on this in
Vietnam but there also was the question
of the draft when young people on
campuses definitely felt more vulnerable
of course they became more interested in
the war and having to go to a war that
they didn't believe in and the whole
you're right about the lesson of Vietnam
which is that you cannot fight a war
unless people understand the reasons why
today and certainly we saw the evolution
of Vietnam Washington Post New York
Times supported the Vietnam War in the
initial stages but gradually when it
came back to the point where where we
were going to have to bomb him to the
stone-age to really win the wars and
they could fade into the night we didn't
even know there was an underground
channel in Saigon we were there 15 years
of the CIA and so forth so there was no
way they could win the war unless they
really did almost a total annihilation
and and American people got really fed
up by that time and they realized that
you know to destroy a village and
restore it and this is what you hear
about Iraq now which is so shocking oh
we're going to we're gonna wipe them out
and by God and then we're gonna build
you see on CNN it says life after the
war there is so much assumption here
that we're practically we've won the war
we're in the war
and there's no . i wish there would be
to be more thinking but i think that
people that the question of
inevitability has sunk in now where
people think we've got no more say about
it congress has given him the green
light and so forth well I think the
people do have us say and I do think
that this White House responds to polls
at least if some in some way if his
polls would continue to go down and he
would see that this was not valid you
know there is no reason Iraq has not
provoked us in any way for eleven years
we've had satellites AWACS overhead we
know everything that moves in Iraq on
the surface we've had typed economic
sanctions where their children have not
been able to get medicine for ordinary
baby illnesses and we bond them and we
bombed them every other night in the
no-fly zone but we don't have reporters
there we don't know where they're going
or anything else not that I don't trust
this government
and then you have the total secrecy they
tell you nothing I wa I think that the
truth doesn't hurt us in any ways not
just Iraq why don't we know about
terrorism why don't we know the causes
they have done everything to sabotage
the the creation establishment of a
commission to look into the causes
how can you rectify a situation how can
you change it how can you make a
difference treat it whatever if you
don't know the reasons and they don't
want you to know the reasons it's not
just political because obviously other
administration's the Clinton
administration will be to blame to I
mean talk about missing the boat all
over the place and not connecting the
dots it wasn't just this administration
but I'm in a tender here which is known
for its intellect and the intellectual
ferment and thinking and there is nobody
in Washington in the higher echelon who
wants to think why there is only one
question on the table and that is why
why are we hated now why should we ever
be hated we've always been loved what
made us lose so much ground and so much
affection and respect in the world thank
you
okay I think we can now open up to our
audience remember what Helen said
dissent is a good thing yes yeah we have
microphones Harry it would be good to
identify yourself since there isn't a
record of this sure my name is Nils von
Stein I'm from I'm a PhD student at the
Sloan School of Management here and I
was interested in hearing more about the
issue of press access to information
regarding Wars for example and how that
access has evolved over your years of
covering the White House and
specifically heaven and how that trend
which seems to be towards less and less
access how that can be changed if in any
way well I think that the media
overlords have really laid down on the
job they should be complaining
protesting the fact does anybody know
anything that's going on do you know we
have a war in Afghanistan not really a
war I mean it's a Special Forces action
police action whatever we aren't
fighting an army navy or anything else
what are we really doing there we've had
no casualty figures or anything else
Rumsfeld struts and swashbuckle is every
day and refuses to answer the questions
acts like everybody is some nincompoop
you know but he for even asking during
the Vietnam war correspondents could hop
on a helicopter and go to any front they
could go anywhere I mean that was a wide
open deal that sure they would attend
the five o'clock Follies that were given
by the Army Headquarters and so forth in
a hotel in Saigon but they also went to
the front and they saw they knew what
was happening and hence you got the
books and hence you got the dispatches
that really questioned what are we doing
there
you don't have that anymore I mean they
have really the word around and this is
strictly rumor what's at the Pentagon
they said never again will we allow a
war to be covered like that and they
drew up a master plan of how to contain
us and they did a good job in the
Persian Gulf War in terms of having
briefings at the at the Pentagon and in
Riyadh and they were very coordinated
and so forth but they wouldn't they
really limited the reporters who could
go to the front now I think that they're
really trying to control everything they
might allow us they're allowing some
reporters on the aircraft carriers in
silver but there is no real real
coverage of these Wars everything is
under their control
spin manipulation management yes in the
blue sure I think thank you very much my
name is Michael Halle I'm an alum and
I'm an instructor at a Harvard Medical
School
I wonder if Helen thank you first for a
for great insight that I think none of
us could get from from any other source
and along those lines one of the things
that I've seen in the last couple years
that I wonder if you could comment on is
really kind of a loss of principle in
how people conduct public affairs I mean
we when we're talking about war in
Serbia there are lots of people who were
saying there's no compelling interest
for Americans to fight this war and
those people are strangely silent now
when the question of interest happens to
cross party lines we saw that in the
elections when the people were
traditionally states rights had always
advocated states rights all of a sudden
wanted Florida to change their you know
how they were wanted to tell a Florida
how to do their elections and it seems
to me that that there there's evidence
of that happening that we see all the
time now and is that is is principal
something that we as maybe younger
people look back on and and say that's
something that have
in the past isn't true in ours that's
something that's always really been
going on and and we've just idealized
what's happened in the past consistency
I mean the treatment of Iraq versus
North Korea to me it shows you the
difference for they're very pragmatic
they do what they can do and they do
what's what is within the realm and they
can knock off Iraq but they're very
difficult to go to the Pacific at this
time and so forth so I think this
question of principle has not entered in
here what is the principle are we
against dictatorships great or do we
think that nobody should have any bombs
but us great I mean but not not gonna
work it can't control all humanity that
way so you have to have a policy
yourself you have to represent something
yourself you have to work for arms
control and you can't tear up everything
and have people look to us as some sort
of Savior then why do we think that
people wouldn't follow preemption once
we make it stick if it's good for us
where is the principle one quick one
quick edition I mean I I think there's
we all have a kind of nostalgia for an
older time when there was greater moral
clarity my guess is that we've probably
that our institutions have probably been
always about as corrupt as they are and
about as good as they are that there's
probably very little case it would be
hard to make a case for a past time that
was more admirable but but I do think
that one it's one strand of the
discourse that I think Charles clarified
for us in his comments is worth
emphasizing again and maybe ought to
become a fuller part of our discussion
which has to do with the failure of
particular institutions Charles's
suggestion in effect and I think he's
right about this is that without the
press we might be at war now I think
that's very likely there has been a
change in the in the in the tone of the
of the bush rhetoric is in the last
couple of weeks and that's surely partly
a consequence of the way the major media
and especially institutions like the New
York Times and The Washington Post in a
kind of relatively quiet way began to
publish op-ed pieces by dissenters who
were varied
linguist like Prime Minister's in Europe
or but or or or or a very important
older Republicans who had served in Bush
woman and the effect of and that I think
that began to build up in an in a way
that that began to certainly had the
consequence of moderating the rhetoric
but the more interesting question to me
is if it's true that our that our press
has been something of a savior here a
very helpful institution it seems to me
the the alternative conclusion would be
forced to be drawn about Congress
because this election ought to be about
the war we are people that the Democrat
people the Democrats ought to be running
against the bush policy but when we cast
our votes tomorrow we're no no matter
which side we're voting for not none of
the politicians who are who are standing
for office now are articulating a clear
position on this question and to me that
means that our political institutions
are not functioning they're not
functioning at the level that it's
healthy society requires I want to
interject one point I do not absolve the
press I think we have rolled over and
played dead we have sent the spin out we
have not there hasn't been any real
decent other side of the question every
Khong columnist colonists I should say
it uh in on the Washington Post everyone
but one or two has been for the war
pumping it up every day every day
demonizing not just Yasser Arafat who
became the demon and they were so
successful wipe him out he's nothing now
I mean Saddam Hussein every day I'm
holding no brief for a monster but I can
assure you that this is definitely a war
drum beat in the middle there yes yes
you
my name is Agee I'm kind of on the 9
year plan here I went here undergrad and
my grad student and MS Thomas has just
anticipated part of one of my questions
and there's about ten tumbling in my
mind so I may be a little inarticulate
but I was wondering professor Stewart
said that he thinks that there's been a
sophisticated discourse in the press and
I feel like just the opposite is true
and that particularly in the traditional
media we're being sort of fed very
simple storylines that people can follow
and also the peace movement I think has
been very much downplayed and ignored
and I was wondering how you think since
miss Thomas it seems that you agreed to
some extent how you think this might
change if you think the pressures of
alternative media might do so or if the
press will and so I might come to its
senses and learn to give facts and be
less frivolous Thanks well let me let me
try to try to stoke it a bit and and and
and and maybe as I understand the
question so the question I guess to
restate what I had stated and maybe we
could talk about it a bit if I said it
was sophisticated well gee um more
sophisticated than I imagined and so
just to kind of rehearse that I mean one
of the things I think we need to
remember is that if we were to try to
find a time in America's past in which
there was a really sophisticated
argument about whether to go toward any
given moment and full-blown dissent
about doing it it would be hard to find
now it wouldn't be that you couldn't
find it it's just that it would be
really really really hard to find and so
when I look for instance in the Gallup
poll or the pew poll there's various
polls and discover
that 36% of the public thinks that going
to war is as a bad idea now some people
think that's a small number but given
past history the fact that we may be
going down award road to war with 36% of
the public saying is a bad idea it's a
new thing in American history and so
that's that's just for one thing is that
that's DIF unexpected and where does
that come from maybe it does come from
the alternate media my guess is it's
coming from whatever people can glean
from the mainstream media because even
though the alternate media has grown
still by and large middle America gets
their news from the broadcast and from
and actually get most of their political
news from the newspapers so that's just
one thing that I mean compared to what
we in Cambridge await a mighty might
want its unsophisticated an uninformed
and pretty supine but compared to
American history it's you know it's
maybe at least descent trying to break
out at the beginning sense the first
thing and the second thing again when
you look inside those polls you see
folks being either schizophrenic or
nuanced you can kind of depend on how
you feel today how you characterize it
nonetheless yes we should go to war but
we should wait we should wait for these
people we know so that again I mean my
guess is that when opposition to the
Vietnam War first broke out I mean I was
I was a mere child at the time but
watching it on newspaper it appeared to
be pretty polarized some pretty bit
realloc and not a whole lot of well on
the one hand well on the other hand and
right now there's a fair amount of well
in one hand well on the other hand the
final thing I guess I'll say is sort of
an offensive congress's which is what I
studied I guess that's my role here is
that you know I was listening to the
radio during the debate and the Senate
and I heard the speech and it was Bob
Graham from Florida and I was just
listening to him talk and I he finished
and I thought gee Bob Graham of Florida
is going to vote against the war how
weird
well in fact he voted for the war
although he gave a speech against it
well well I took to be you know these
are all the reasons why this is a stupid
idea and you know if you're really gonna
do this these are the things you got to
convince us of and this is where you're
gonna kind of do if you screw up it's
your fault
that's interesting so you know so this
doesn't exactly kind of address your
point except to say I do think that I do
think that the messages out there are
more diverse than they would have been
30 to 40 years ago and just as
government has learned lessons of
Vietnam I think the press and the public
learned lessons from Vietnam one of
those is just to be be skeptical and
just keep in mind there are strong
pressures in any country at any given
point at this moment to go along with
the leaders notice the history good
point of governments and their citizens
and the fact that we have a third of our
citizens saying this is not a good thing
is at least a glass half full without
revealing my age I would like to say
that before World War two there was a
real split in this country between the
interventionists and the
non-interventionist Hitler was was on
the move and so forth
but we had people like Gerald old case
Smith by the cogman and so forth and the
other side very very Pro German and and
the memory of memories of World War one
gassing and all of the horeb over done
and the terrible terrible things that in
that war I mean the memory lived long
into the third thirties and it wasn't I
mean there was a real split in this
country in a real debate went on day
after day was very strong and of course
FDR obviously felt that we were going to
have to get in at some point in terms of
giving lend-lease to Britain and so for
giving as much support as he could to
Churchill and the inevitability but then
Pearl Harbor of course you know made the
decision for all of us and then we
rallied everybody rallied around the
flag and had to and realize that Hitler
had to be stopped
so
but there was real real debate between
the interventionists and the
non-interventionist let me take someone
from the back and then I'll come to the
front next please someone would give
that person to microphone my name whoa
hi there my name is Ellen frist I used
to be a staff person here at MIT I've
received a Master of Divinity from
Harvard and I work a lot with
non-violence I was a Peace Corps
volunteer in Morocco so I know a lot
about what's been happening with this
kind of Islam bashing Helen thank you
very much for all of your candidness and
I agree with you 100%
thank you and I do think that the
Congress has been very weak in standing
up even the constituents in this state
who have asked John Kerry that we don't
want there to be a yes vote for the war
and he voted yes anyway so there is an
alternative Democratic candidate that's
a write-in candidate her name is Randall
forsberg and her address is 950 Mass Ave
Cambridge and she is oh is a write-in
candidate for John Kerry
for me having lived and just coming back
from the Middle East I'm very concerned
about what can be the repercussions if
we go ahead and have a war with Iraq
because we will not we're not safe now
but we really won't be safe if we do go
ahead and walk into Iraq so I'd like to
hear anyone on the panel talk about what
does that say around our ethics around
our children around the children at knee
in Iraq and about what you think some of
the repercussions are going to be not
just politically thank you
well my first reaction is I I think that
I think that John Kerry's yes vote is
particularly contemptible coming from
him and I think that John Kerry's vote
is a rebel is a is a signal to us about
why we should not vote for him for
president just clearly his motivation I
spoke from anti-war platforms with John
Kerry in California in 1966-67 and and
he was when he came back from Vietnam
and stand as a Vietnam veteran spoke out
against the war he was one of the most
important early public voices against
the war who really got attention I mean
those of us who had been arguing against
the war for a much longer time were
unknowns and we couldn't get any press
coverage and it was a kind of shocking
situation in which it really Helen was
right that what really happened was
middle class kids started to die and
then what soon as them as soon as the
middle class realized that it in in the
United States that its own that its own
children were being sacrificed in the
war the anti-war movement became a
became a majority movement but it wasn't
up until then and I mean I think Charles
is point about 36% of the population
already raising questions about Iraq
means that our situation now is very
different from our situation then but it
may well be that the sources of our
support are going to come from ordinary
folk not people like John Kerry who are
dreaming of becoming president if I
could just just say a word word about
that I mean me what I think I know
something about is public opinion and so
I tried so I tried to give maybe maybe a
hopeful view of this but if you want the
non hopeful view I think that a
combination of what Helen said earlier
and what you suggested just now is
actually the unhelpful the unhelpful
scenario and one of the reasons why it's
important to be in dissent now so one
Road says that we won't go to war for
whatever reason they're actually people
arguing that a cost
Quinn said the last couple of months
mean that in the end we won't go to war
but there is one scenario that says we
will eventually go to war and I'm not an
expert but you know folks I've talked to
have had who've been around the world
and lived in that part of the world have
convinced me that should we go to a real
war then we will in fact be in much
greater danger a much greater peril okay
from basically that part of the world
and you know taking it out on us one way
or the other
if that should happen then the real
danger is America's the Americans who
are dissenting and wondering right now
will flip in the same way as Helen was
noting before the Second World War that
you know the dissent or the questioning
about internationalism and intervention
went away with Pearl Harbor and so I
again it's the reason why if you oppose
the action you know the row we're going
on in Iraq you know now is the time to
dissent and now is the time to act
because should we go to war and should
the worst-case scenario play out the
folks middles are middle class Americans
who right now are wondering will turn
and become loyal
I mean and we'll become loyal to
whatever the policy exactly and so so I
mean it's not probably not not what you
wanted to hear and not a full engagement
with with the issue but it does seem to
me from what I know about public opinion
is that there is a real perilous Road
that could be even worse than it is
right and even without a war in Iraq
what Charles is describing could happen
anyway another attack on an on an
American institution is going to have a
an effect like that Americans will rally
around so I we're obviously in very
precarious circumstances one message I
think everyone is saying people both in
the panelists and in the audience is
that we're where we suffer from a lack
of leadership in the country that we're
not we're not the leaders of the country
are not are not being helpful at this
terrible terrible
in our history this is gentleman right
here please
my name is Dana Donovan I'm a visiting
scholar here and I'd be interested in
hearing perhaps just as an intellectual
exercise which we love here at MIT from
any member of the panel do you see
anything redeeming so far in the current
presidency or any hope for anything
redeeming coming out of our current
president I'm actually asking that
seriously well he has a short attention
span there's an election in two years I
think that he's so hell-bent for war
that it's very hard to find the
redeeming factor you know I wish it was
a bluff I pray I want to be wrong on
everything and I don't understand why he
can't see the consequences why he
doesn't think there'll be more terrorism
if we actually we can win anything we've
got to know how we're the king of the
mountain
and there's no question that we're but
we're also going to be the bullets of
the Western world and do we really want
that reputation and for what I mean we
really respect people in this world and
they have their own way I'm not saying I
don't want democracy to spread I do want
it but not through our warfare into
bombs yes please
hi my name is Erica Taylor and I'm a
broadcast journalism graduate student at
Boston University and my question is
directed to you Miss Thomas in terms of
you say that the press rolls over in
place ed what advice do you have for
up-and-coming journalists in terms of
how we can maybe separate the press from
the government and cover things not so
much jaded by what public opinion is and
more so what we feel ethically speaking
the question is essentially how can
young journalists you tell them that you
pay them the taxpayer pays them and they
have to answer it they are public
servants if they don't like with that
we'll give up the job and you definitely
you can't be rude as I am but but you
definitely have to remind them they are
public servants and they are accountable
and they are supposed to answer
questions I mean if it's a deep dark
secret that would affect national
security no of course not
I mean you wouldn't want to jeopardize
the lives of troops Ernie but every
question is legitimate
I believe practically didn't go to
public sources like politicians where
would you go apart from apart from the
traditional sources of information to
find out the truth how would a what what
should a journalists do in that way
instead of just accepting what the
politicians tell us well I said I think
you have to find the leak you have you
have to find some dissenter who doesn't
mind telling you the truth and who is so
upset
there aren't many deep throats around
but sometimes I think you have to find
out is everyone solid in that position
and if they're not you have to find out
what what is the break a lot of in this
this president doesn't tolerate leaks
and he doesn't I mean he's got a solid
front and so forth and they were all
very much aware that they have to be on
board so it's very hard to find that
breaking point as there was in Bush one
even when you had
differences of opinion are even Reagan
when you had Jim Baker on one side and
Ed meals and the others and so it was a
real split but there'll always be
someone who's going to try to save the
country and you do need whistleblowers
that's true we've got to find them in a
way but they have to answer the
questions I mean they are accountable
and I think you have to remind them may
get the mad you may not get the answer
but you may put them on notice yes this
gentleman there yes right there yeah
thank you
my name is George McCray I live in
central square there's a very
interesting book that I've read this
year called defying Hitler by Sebastian
Hafner and I don't mean to imply that
the Bush administration are fascists
because they don't believe that they are
fascists or Nazis
I believe the corporatist which is
something different the book is
interesting because it's written was
written in 38 and put away and it's a
clear the clearest explanation I know of
how the process of the not suffocation
happened and reading that book was very
scary to me because many of the same
things seemed to be going on and when
you have senator byrd on the floor of
the senate quoting Goering as he did
when you have a high-ranking person in
the German government making a comment
about the similarities between some of
the tactics of the Bush administration
and the Nazi government and then being
fired for it things become very dicey
when you have the one person in the
Senate who voted against the war
suddenly dying in an airplane crash
there are many people whose noses are
twitching whose stomachs are a little
uneasy and I would hope that we find out
what really happened to that plane
because when you read the when you read
about that incident they're talking
about what's the political fallout but
they don't talk about what happened to
the plane and then you read another
article that says Mondale is asked
whether he's going to travel by plane
and he says no only by bus so I don't
mean to be impolite but I think that we
really have to examine the the
possibility that things are are much
darker than we think
I hope you're all and I don't believe
things are I think I think I think these
I think things are terrible enough not
to require conspiracy theories there are
enough there are enough simple
explanations for why things are so
terrible so that they don't require that
we imagine even worse conspiracies yeah
I don't believe in there is any
conspiracy there has been a chipping
away of civil liberties during fine but
getting along they're making great
inroads into our rights and so forth so
they don't really have to resort to
anything as underhanded as that horrible
believe the notion that well stones
plane was shut down or was sabotage by
by Iraqi war mongers or by Bush but
makes no sense from many angles one of
the reasons would be it's not as if well
stone was the only one who had spoken
out against these things nor is it a
question of well stone having any power
so it's very hard it's very hard to see
the usefulness of such a of such an
account of the world when um what a much
more straightforward account of the
world is sufficient to cause horrific
nightmares
yes please my name is Elizabeth laws and
I'm an undergraduate here at MIT
studying economics and think you must
Thomas I enjoyed your presentation um I
see under President Bush's power
I do see hopefulness and that's in that
he has the power to take us to war and
then he hasn't done it yet and his
professor Stewart said and I'm a fine
example of our public opinion is going
from a really scared very vulnerable
post September 11th America looking for
a football coach to rally us and take us
to war and now we're starting to think
about it and we're starting to talk
about it and question whether this is
really what we need to do and I think
we're asking for more from him and of
course the press is helping and but I
think we're looking for a plan I'm also
not anti-war I don't think what we need
is more of a grass roots war is evil and
unjust because of course it is but we
also have to be a realist and think
about America and what what it stands
for and why maybe we do need to go to
war one day and under certain
circumstances and I think what we need
to look for from him is a plan that we
can defend internationally and
ideologically and morally and openly one
that hopefully is a multilateral affect
and doesn't need to be done in the next
few years because Iraq won't have
nuclear weapons at least for a few years
but I'm curious as to what you think
about the possibility in the future of
having to go to war by necessity because
of the threat that a ruler like Saddam
Hussein who I think has vehement plans
against the United States and would like
to have a nuclear weapon to harm us and
also and more right now al Qaeda who
obviously would love to hurt us again
and what you think we should be doing
against them I mean we're basically a
war against Al Qaeda now and it's a hard
war to fight because
it's not a traditional one but I'm just
curious what you think about it on a
more finite terms as opposed to the
ideology of it
well Saddam Hussein has never threatened
the United States he may threaten Israel
and they when in terms of the whole
question of the Middle East but he's
never threatened the United States so
you gotta find a reason to attack him
and I don't think you should find one I
really don't think that we should go
looking for provocation when there is
none I mean we're talking about human
beings we're talking about human lives
you going balmy Rocky why why I'm gonna
kill Americans why are you willing to
give your life I mean to mean to respond
to the question it strikes me that that
you've almost given me I think the
answer to your own question in your life
what you're talking about your life
story it strikes me I was out he yelled
at any school someone went to Harvard
Divinity School and was very much
influenced by the Vietnam years and
considered myself a passive US for many
years I still do I thank um but the
thing that's really striking about the
state of September 11th attacks talking
to my friends who kind of grew up under
the same circumstances began to realize
there may really be conditions under
which we could support war and one of
those would be nations doing horrible
things to us very well beyond and so and
what's also striking kind of in public
opinion is that Americans have a lot of
Americans used to be anti-war not all
but many beginning think well maybe yes
maybe you know and there are some
traditions about thinking about that
Just War tradition and others and so
it's strike so it seems to me that one
of the reasons why it's it's really
interesting that so many Americans are
wondering about Iraq is that that wonder
and skepticism about Iraq comes at the
same time that there's kind of greater
willingness in general
to find reasons to retaliate by war and
so I mean I wouldn't want to speak from
his Thomas Thomas or for David but but
it strikes me that most of us nowadays
would say well you know if we get
attacked for for whatever reason and one
can you know blame the United States for
a lot in the world and quite understand
why it is the people would want to hate
us but you know don't do horrible things
to us or we may have in fact respond
that's different from a pre-emptive war
which the which this country and many of
us are discovering we've never had a
tradition of I have one quick response I
mean I think that there was an answer to
your question and in the question as
well which is that we are already at war
the most shocking aspect of this
business about Iraq is the fact that
it's not as if the Bush administration
has been so brilliantly successful in
its alleged war on terrorism if we start
looking at it at its record in fact I
think that that I'm shocked that a
democratic politician isn't running
against the Bush administration for its
incompetence in protecting us in the war
on terrorism airports are still just as
dangerous as they ever were there's
overwhelming evidence that all that
would that we remain incredibly
vulnerable to a single sniper and yet we
and yet we mean the first single sniper
paralyzed Washington for three weeks and
the and the FBI the CIA and the police
forces of Maryland and Washington were
incapable of catching them immediately
and this was just to two individuals
that I mean there's I think there's
overwhelming evidence that the war on
terrorism is a serious business I don't
think that the Bush administration is
taking it seriously enough because if
they were they would not be talking
about extending them to creating a
second war that's one response but but I
have something else to say I'm sorry to
sound so weirdly radical it's not like
me but the fact of the matter is if you
put yourself in the position of someone
not in the United States but living
anyplace else in the world and if you
asked someone living in France or
someone living in the Middle East or
someone living in Russia where which is
the most dangerous country in the world
which country in the world you think is
most likely to start dropping bombs on
civilians do you think that the answer
would be Saddam Hussein or George Bush
the United States is right now the most
dangerous and the most law apparently
potentially lawless country in the world
and where we really need if we wanted to
address our if we wanted to address
questions of peace of being up being
peaceful good neighbors we would we
would be much more aggressive in
attacking the immoral behavior of our
president right back there our last
question or comment yes right there
thank you okay thank you very much to
all thank you miss Thomas you've been a
role model in particular for me I'm a
journalist from Europe my name is nadya
christen and i go to school at the
Fletcher School my question is regarding
the international media when you and
your colleagues get together at
different press clubs or different
reunions you have and you talk about the
way you report on whatever President
Bush plan is for for Iraq do you ask
your yourself and your colleagues how is
the European media for instance
reporting how is our Jazeera reporting
or other media outlets in in the Middle
East and if they do report different and
I think they do do you ask yourself why
you're not trying to report differently
if you have this frustration that the
media is basically aligned with the
president thank you
little negotiations I think we're very
interested in foreign coverage that's
for sure and we were very interested
when the national security affairs
advisor went to CNN another cable
outlets and told them not to use certain
things on al Jazeera which is very
uncalled it's not the way we do things I
mean this is not the way a free press
operates you let it all hang out you let
the chips fall where they may
that's where truth is so I'm certainly
aware that we are not liked in this
country anymore that our country is not
like where it was loved before everybody
who's travelled last summer came back
from Europe and so forth came back with
hair-raising tales about how how the new
Europeans were viewing us as not only
war mongers but not but lacking an
understanding yes we do care this is a
global village CMM can go anywhere in
five minutes
everybody's war is in your living room
it is one world and we certainly every
time anything happens anywhere I think
we are affected and certainly when you
cover the White House you get it all
from tricky track to everything that
happens in the world we are affected and
I think that we do worry and I think we
have to refurbish our image it's really
gone down badly and I don't know if the
White House is really aware or really
cares not when you think of
unilateralism and say who in the hell
cares you know we're we're on top we can
wipe out anyone where the
but that's not the way the world works
and I'm afraid that they've bit off more
than they can chew if they don't care
what our image is Helen you're a delight
your subject isn't and you may not count
all that well but I know you count for
this audience and therefore you count
for MIT so I just on behalf of our
institution and the communications forum
I want to thank you and of course your
wonderful colleagues my friends for
putting on a wonderful show for us today
you